the black one has some goop in its butt
black one a certain coupe in its butt
puppy poops like regular dog poop
acceptance smaller and it comes from a
cuter but it is so hard to answer
questions while these dogs are here when
will was there was my first year so I
was still trying to figure out where the
bathrooms work yeah you didn't I ever
did I you always just went where I stood
guys please
I learned that Amy loves reading Paul
really any give me your paw I can get
things from life line Loveline
success/failure these are your kids the
middle of your palm talks about what you
want the top of your hand talks about
like that it's a little obnoxious
I learned that will will drives one of
those recumbent bikes to work
he likes to lay in back that's how he
gets everywhere with a flag arm workout
yeah yep it takes a really long time to
get to set and he's got what I mean
great white a few accidents I think she
win I just feel like she's know well she
knows a little bit your buddy would do
but he has this size but he has a size
well he might inadvertently hurt Leslie
like like like it water like a mice and
message exactly
I think they did the best ice the year
before would just be M Kofi fake yeah
okay
[Music]
did you ever bring your child kids home
a puppy I did and then I had to take it
away like an hour later it turns out
they didn't deserve it I'm gonna call
this guy lazy but my easy bones and I'll
call this guy good-for-nothing here this
is an uncle that's Peter close up there
making out they're making out
I guess it's when you try to yeah that's
an awkward moment do that and your
co-star is not ready for it right when
you go to kiss them and then you after a
couple kisses try to kiss them in the
private area that's another which is
what just happened this is these two
puppies re-enacting a scene that will
and I did got cut for time it didn't
test well
I really wish I hadn't gone back for the
last season of ER that you had gone back
know that I have because I had a great
run as dr. Peter Willoughby and they
asked me to come back for one more
season it was done these this is our
director and assistant director
assistant director that they all have
any creative differences but it always
comes out great
[Music]
gosh what would I do I'd probably get on
the subway and just man spread much as I
could I take up so many seats
if I were Amy I would love to buy an
economy ticket on any airline and
pretend like it was a king-sized bed I
get concentrate
there's too many puppies here does she
run a pet store now yeah yeah I don't
know let me think about some um she runs
a pet store now with puppies running
around Ron Burgundy is on his sailboat
right now oh my god you two were
embarrassing me you're embarrassing your
mother in our movie the house we have a
you know it's all about gambling
you know should we bet money on these
puppies fighting each other right now or
that's illegal no never mind already
scratched up eww we can't what we're not
we didn't get a or at least we don't be
in it the puppies are on strike